what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and marvel surprised
us this morning by announcing a
new marvel disney plus show with already
so much in the lineup not only coming
out in the theaters but a lot of disney
plus shows scheduled to come out this
year and
next year the schedule for phase four is
already jam-packed
but marvel being as awesome as they are
thought to grace us with another disney
plus
show this one a little bit different
than the others but really
really awesome nonetheless this is going
to come out right after
one division the very week after and is
going to be called marvel studios
assembled and this disney plus show is
actually going to take us behind
the scenes of the other disney plush
shows so we have
a lot of new content for marvel coming
out so if you want to stay up to date on
everything be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
so this is what marvel studios is symbol
it is going to be
about according to them on their website
they say
now that you've watched the marvel
cinematic universe come to life on both
the big and small screen see how it all
initially came together with marvel
studios is
assembled the new comprehensive
documentary series of specials goes
behind the scenes of the shows and
movies of the mcu
following the filmmakers cast and crew
and marvel heroes
every step of the way assembled will
take viewers through productions such as
wanda vision
the falcon and the winter soldier and
loki via exclusive on-set
footage join filmmakers and stars like
scarlett johansson and jeremy renner as
they detail the genesis of the black
widow film and the hawkeye series
arriving on the streaming service
shortly after theatrical releases and
series completions assembled
is an immersive and in-depth examination
of the next phase of the marvel
cinematic universe and will arrive soon
on disney plus
the first episode of assembled will
focus on the critically acclaimed one
division
join elizabeth olsen paul bettany and
one division's creative team as the
episode pulls back the curtain on this
highly groundbreaking series
learn how the production surprising
concept took shape by drawing
inspiration from classic sitcoms
witness how the crew went to great
lengths to emulate various filmmaking
methods used during the early years of
television
discover the unique challenges and
ultimate rewards of performing an entire
episode in front of a live
studio audience spend time with exciting
newcomers to the mcu such as tayonna
paris and catherine hong
along with returning favorites like kat
dennings and randall park
assembled the making of one division
premiering on march
12th is an all-encompassing look at
marvel studios first
and arguably most unusual streaming
series
so basically this is going to take us
behind the scenes of these disney plus
shows and some movies as it mentioned
black widow in a way that we've never
really seen before
and the way that they're doing this is
actually rather unique they're going to
be releasing
a new version of assembled after each
individual marvel studios project that
gets released
and this is going to help bridge the gap
in between marvel studios projects for
example
one division is going to end on march
5th this episode of
assembled is going to come out on march
12th and then
on march 19th we're going to have the
falcon and the winter soldier so it's
really like
marvel is trying to get us to go zero
time without marvel they're trying to
give us marvel content
literally every week and this was a
great way to kind of make up for the
pandemic and not really having anything
in 2020
not that it was their fault but it's
great of them to do and as you heard
them say this is going to happen after
the falcon and the winter soldier
black widow the loki series and the
hawkeye series so
literally this entire year is going to
be jam-packed with
marvel content it's going to be
absolutely incredible
and i hope everybody is just as excited
as i am but let me know your thoughts
about this
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video if you enjoyed it and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos about the mcu
and it looks like there is going to be a
lot for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you